So today I'll be presenting some data on our Phase 2 study of oral Dacitabine plus Venetoclax
as a fully oral option for AML.
So as we know, acute myeloid leukemia is predominantly a disease of older adults.
These patients are challenging to treat because they have a higher comorbidity burden, lower
physiological reserve, and also have a higher incidence of adverse risk AML genetics.
And they may not be candidates for intensive chemotherapy or allergenic stem cell transplantation.
The Phase 3 Viali-A study established Aza-Venetoclax as the standard of care in this patient population.
ASTX-727 is an oral formulation of Dacitabine with pharmacokinetic AUC exposure equivalent
to IV Dacitabine.
So this now allows a fully oral HMA-VEN combination for AML.
So this was a Phase 2 study looking at that, and there's both a frontline arm and a relapsed
refractory arm in this study.
These are the eligibility criteria.
This was a study for patients.
This is a study of AML over age 18.
In the frontline or older unfit cohort, patients needed to be either age 75 or above or have
a major comorbidity, including intensive chemotherapy.
The primary objective was overall response rate.
Secondary objectives were overall survival, relapse-free survival, duration of response,
and safety.
This is a treatment plan.
So the treatment was given in 28-day cycles, up to 24 cycles.
Induction was five days of ASTX-727.
And this was a study of AML over age 18.
And venetoclax was given with a three-day ramp-up, then up until day 28.
However, the venetoclax could be held at day 21 based on an early bone marrow if the blast
had cleared.
And the dose of venetoclax was adjusted for concomitant CYP384 inhibitors.
Consolidation was five days of ASTX-727 and 21 days of venetoclax, although the doses
were permitted to be reduced to three days for ASTX and 14 days for venetoclax in patients
where there was a concern for myelosuppression or toxin.
So this was a study of AML over age 18.
And this was a study of AML over age 18.